preseason went against the Cowboys my
rams beat them 2824 Jared golf the Rams
quarterback joins us back on the program
how's morale with the Rams here Jared
it's good to ask you it's good you know
I skim the lantern came back here good
morning
start with fin feel good okay what
happened have you ever been stuck in
traffic where you might have been late
for a meeting you try to plan that in
advance you try to make sure you know
leave time for that because you know
down here that can't happen what happens
like if you're late for have you been
late for a meeting
no no never you can't do that but if you
did if you did and it was because of
traffic you're in trouble you got to
find however much they want to make it
uh what do you take away from that game
against the Cowboys uh I think it was a
good team win and there was a lot of
good things that we did I think
offensively we started a bit slow and I
got lucky with the other bus plant were
able to finish I drive with a touchdown
I think that's no that's real football
you get chance like that you go these we
took advantage of it and in a second or
third units a good job as well moving
the ball and ultimately went in this
game how different is it not having
those hard knock cameras there oh it's
great man it's a lot different it's a
lot different you know those guys were
really very good to us but you know not
having to look over your shoulder think
about you know what am i listening to
look for music or what am i saying at
the PD room younger things like that you
see yourself it's fun but did you ever
feel like there was going to be
something put and put on that could have
embarrassed you or you would embarrassed
yourself all the time yes kind of think
about it you know you know you have some
sort of you know perception that you'd
like people have are you thinking about
you know what this make the show you
know you sure hope not but they say they
said we had final cut no you did and
until we don't you know midnight I got
there and we don't so it was overall
good experience as you would expect
McLovin has a great poll question a
hard-hitting poll question for you that
is from its Rambo
McLovin you want to give Jared the poll
question okay I did want to throw it our
buddy Sean Mannion this
I can't better hair is I told Charles
come along with you so he's excited I
know he's eliciting right now who has
better hair
I had coach Sean McVeigh or a
quarterback Jared Goff better hair ooh
ham for sure he puts because he's got
the product and every day he's hit a
little spike in the front I know I'll
use much stuff he takes care of his for
sure who cares more about their hair em
it's for sure I like I said people you
know sticking out faces pretty I I just
kind of wear had a lot so don't think
about it too much how much older is he
than you what he's very warm try turn 23
a month so eight nine years right now
will be eight them off
is it weird at all because we always
think of the coaches like 25 years older
than the players yeah you know it's it
really hasn't been it's very good screws
and a good experience especially with
older guys on the team you see the
respect that they have for having and
for me you know being so young it's not
it's no different for me but you know
guys like Andrew Whitworth and John
Sullivan who are you know older than him
that have so much respect for him and
speak so highly of them you know
privately with myself other people it
just gives you that you know confidence
that he's you know on top of what he's
doing and he's been great so far
Jared Goff Rams quarterback joining a
stand Patrick show the difference of
going in this year to last year can you
put it into words how you feel yeah just
you know obviously though I'm doing a
bit more understanding of what's what's
going on offensively defensively just
stuff thrown as a player and a person
and matured and physically gone bigger
everything's got a little bit slower
it's it's been a good you know
transition this year the first preseason
game is Dallas when it weren't much
better than watch it for sure Sammy
Watkins your new best friend oh yeah
yeah families I'm excited to get to work
with on my knees he's just just got here
couple days ago
yesterday I guess and I'm excited to see
what he can do but I I didn't understand
last year you know Gurley didn't have a
year the line wasn't great I just didn't
know if you had enough weapons
offensively do you feel like you now
have weapons that can put you you know
that are comparable to what other
quarterbacks in the NFL have
you know I think I think you know I'm
excited about what they've done about
this offseason for sure I think you know
less and you know the rest of the
management have done a really good job
just adding the right guys not only guys
that can play bad guys that are good
good people and good players and and
care really care you know Robert Woods
Andrew Whitworth John so I mean even the
guys were drafted with Cooper Cup and
sure lever and I'm just speaking up
pencil here and I was plenty guys on
defense we've done the same thing with
but now I think I got like Sammy really
really bolster that receiver room and
really make it you know conflict cover
everybody we got a bunch of studs over
there out there now and it's going to be
a lot of fun spreading the ball around
and what most guys do the thing we often
hear that guys who were in college then
go to the NFL say you know you wait for
the game to slow down a little bit and
it takes a little bit of time to do that
but I think with a quarterback it's
slowing down
the game but also processing information
how quickly they give it to you you spit
it out you understand it you see
coverage like that that's something that
can't be taught Canada I mean it you
almost have to experience it there yeah
I think so I think though a lot of it
has to do with you know going through it
and last year I did go through it with
you know and women in my games on seven
games I played I did go through you know
getting a playful and having hit it out
and out there not processing talking
about but I think through those seven
games experience I gained like you're
talking about being able to understand a
little bit slower and you know
everything starts to slow down a bit and
then coming into this offseason even
more so and even more so coming into
this last game I felt just so much more
comfortable and so much more
understanding of everything give me a
complex play call and I'll try to guess
what the play is all over a lot to do
that if you give me an older one now and
older one can give me you know I'll do
it easier on triple right civil-rights
be short eighty to do oh that's a pretty
simple one I've found too much complex
I'm going to say that's an underneath
route to table in Austin no no it's not
it's a run play yeah it used to be your
stairs
yeah you used to have that option if you
if you wanted to do it you could it was
it was a runner passes what I remember
it used to be sure no I used to be
anymore yeah if you check down you would
have found
when you did go to girly then you got
stopped and you should have thrown the
underneath route to table in Austin but
these are things that we learned you're
not it I mean I played freshman year and
I guess you're one of that's your one
year - yes I know you got a meeting
coming up and we'd hate for you to be
late
tailed it would be not fun for my
pocketbook
yeah but Mannion would laugh because
he'd get more playing time tell-tell
Shawn my fellow rover oh no no that's
Jared gone Rams quarterback my Rams
quarterback they're the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience